most people who describe the walking
dead to their friends and family use the
word zombie when trying to give a shot
synopsis of the popular post-apocalyptic
horror show the show follows a group of
survivors as they attempt to fend off
undead creatures looking to feast on
humans the monsters from the series are
for all intents and purposes zombies and
dead creatures whose corpses were
supernaturally reanimated who've owned
the world near soundlessly so why don't
the characters on The Walking Dead
actually refer to said monsters as
zombies they're called literally
everything else walkers monsters Roma's
geeks lurkers biters the infected
empties and whatõs the Spanish word for
dead but not once in the 10 seasons of
The Walking Dead has the word zombie
crossed the lips of a single character
on the show
Robert Kirkman who co-created The
Walking Dead comic books and executive
produces a television series had an
explanation for the omission was
speaking to Conan O'Brien we wanted to
avoid that notion of hey why isn't that
character just you know shooting that
zombie in the head because I saw those
movies I saw based on Kirkman's comments
leaving the word zombie out to the
Walking Dead has been an extremely
deliberate omission all along and one
that makes a ton of sense The Walking
Dead takes place in a universe where you
know zombie fiction doesn't exist you
know no one inside The Walking Dead has
seen a Romero movie in other words
there's no reference to the word zombie
on The Walking Dead because the word
simply doesn't exist in that universe
any zombies out there oh say that what
that even though the word has never used
on screen in the popular series Kirkman
did cop to the fact that he himself
refers to the walking dead as a zombie
show he also added that the word is
regularly set on sets and actually
written in the scripts despite never
making it into the dialogue on the
series as far as we're concerned that
gives us permission to continue calling
them zombies even if we never hear the
word Ezard on a single episode the
series on the other hand will continue
using clever ways to avoid stating the
c-word characters will forever call the
undead creatures walkers and plenty of
other colorful options though the
Walking Dead team has gone out of their
way to avoid using zombie on the series
the word has popped up a few times
within kirklands comic series in the
second issue of The Walking Dead
Glenn Bri instructs Rick Grimes to take
a giant leap from the roof of one
buildings
roof of another rig says that there's no
way that he's going to do that but Glenn
tells him he doesn't have a choice
unless he wants to die it's in this
exchange that the word zombie is used
Len tells rec you're gonna have to
listen it's easy I do it all the time
when we climbed down this building those
things will still be waiting for us at
the bottom of that building and there's
no way out of that one all these
buildings are filled with zombies trust
me
the word is again used a few issues
later Rick actually employs it twice in
the same conversation telling fellow
survivor Tyreese when we can't near
Atlanta we went into the city most of
the zombies just sat around not doing
anything unless provoked then that camp
was attacked a pack of those things just
tore through us killed two of our
friends so I got a thing that there are
other kinds of zombies that roam around
always on the move
since both occurrences off the Z word
show up fairly early in the comics the
use of the word likely comes down to
Kirkman still deciding what the world of
the Walking Dead was going to look like
regardless Sambi zombie roma or Walker
no matter what you call them we're just
glad they're totally fictional Deadwood
don't say it why not because it's
ridiculous alright
are there any out there though check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the pal so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]